nommée meilleure actrice au festival de
berlin de 2012 pour son rôle d'un enfant
soldat dans le film rebelle de kembo
yens rachel muanza a goûté à la gloire
les plateaux de télévision se
bousculaient pour entendre son histoire
celle d'une survivante de la rue de
kinshasa devenue comédienne il veut
d'être international c'est qu'il m'est
arrivé dans la ville jusqu'à 20 comme
une star décembre est assez fou et les
gens dansent appui moi aussi c'est
incroyable mais moi même je suis étonné
parce que je connais c'est moi qui a
vécu tout s'est fait sans croyable mon
histoire un jour qui va sortir du ventre
après rebelles
rachel muanza s'est installé à montréal
grâce au soutien de l'équipe du film
depuis ce succès la comédienne est
retourné une seule fois en république
démocratique du congo
elle devait y rester un mois je suis
resté cinq jours malheureusement parce
que ç'a vraiment été dur pour moi de
voir mon pays dans cet état mais je me
demande le gouvernement déjà démonté
communs peuvent siffler hâte d'en voir
sa population mourir de faim les gens
qui souffrent les travail au québec
la comédienne est retourné à l'école et
elle travaille à temps partiel dans un
commerce au détail malgré le succès de
rebelles elle a dû patienter près de
sept ans avant de faire un autre film je
vous avoue quand même que j'avais des
propositions mais c'est le truc est
toujours qui ressemble beaucoup à reibel
j'avais vraiment envie de vivre quelque
chose de différent
comment un beau monde ce quelque chose
de différent et la comédie dramatique
troisièmes noces un récit d'un mariage
arrangé entre nouveau sexuelle
une ressortissante congolaise ici on est
très loin du film rebelle j'avais
vraiment envie d ça pour montrer que
je pète dont avec la comédie oui j'irai
cracher jeter leurs intérêts car la
coupe du plus du film troisièmes noces
est aussi la mère adoptive de rachel
muanza qu'elle a rencontré lors du
tournage de rebelles c'est très bien de
ce film là suffire de rachel
c'est ça je les aime beaucoup ça fait
des années donc ça ce qui lui ferait
rachel muanza s permettant que le film
troisièmes noces ou relancera sa
carrière l'homme propose dieu dispose
je pourrais jamais imaginé là où je suis
aujourd'hui je laisse tour entre les
mains des matières ici louis philippe
ouimet radio canada montréal